hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you
oh
[Music]
how are you guys doing it's been a long
time since I had the champ with me since
I had the big man with me yes because I
have the man the plan with the new news
station what's the news station called
s2jnews.com really oh yes that's
fantastic and what you've been doing on
this we've been covering news on a
regular basis that's related to Muslims
and Islam and uh we're working with
volunteers really yeah yeah welcome I
have to say I'm very impressed you know
I tried to do a new station myself as
you know
it's more functional yeah fantastic
writers
CCN yeah continues yeah so but it's not
as operational as your one is and that's
why I want to say to my volunteers or
the people that I work with me you know
you're going to let me outstrip US
you're gonna let our stripper well
Fidelity
this is what the competition let the
competition happen let the games begin
but if it doesn't do well uh then no
it's not it's not my fault I was gonna
say um something has been good on the
news this week and uh some impressive
responses I think is this individual
here yeah his name is Shakila afsar
we're probably familiar with him because
of what was going on with LGBT being
taught in Birmingham schools and martial
again he was a very vocal very active
there does represent a group or anything
like that not that I know of to be
honest he's martial I just just come to
the Forefront and he's been doing a
fantastic job oh I was very impressed
because I saw this clip recently and and
he's taking on an unforgettable opponent
he's taking on Knights of farage who for
those who don't know was the leader of
the ukip party for some time British
politics uh was instrumental in Britain
actually going independent from the
European Union uh breaking away from it
um and has a record of success
politically speaking from his
perspective at least so this is a
formidable opponent and the way he deals
with here I was very much impressed with
him I'm very strapped watching this yeah
that the politics and division of the
subcontinent is now playing out on the
streets and Cinemas of Birmingham what
we must remember that this is a film
being supported by the current Indian
Administration but more the uh one thing
you can already see kind of like a
colonial narrative here goes like what's
happening in your countries is coming to
us yes he's speaking to a person whose
country was colonized by England and the
British Empire for now around 200 years
yeah more longer than that much longer
than this and the divisions and the
revolts and all those kind of things
that happen so this using this as a as a
way to start the conversation in the
first place already shows you what kind
of tone he wants to to set with this
what we must also remember is as as
British citizens we have accountability
to the people of Kashmir this film
directly perpetuates that if you say
free Kashmir you are Isis terrorist
as British citizens so he's bringing it
back so listen I was much British as you
are do you see wow and it's it was a
good it was a good way to get center of
the Ring I think and this is a good
demonstration of how to deal with an
aggressive opponent actually you know
get center of the ring you'll see this
um he does this he doesn't allow for us
to assert himself this film perpetuates
that if you use the term free Kashmir
and as you will know that according to
the United Nations resolution the
kashmiris have been promised the right
of self-determination and the British is
directly responsible for the mess that
has been left behind in the Asian
subcontinent we cannot wash ourselves
away the breakup just just
to answer your question I believe I
believe that this is propaganda by the
Indian Administration and the Narendra
Modi who has made this tax-free
no this is really good because now he
didn't let him interject that was
fantastic that was brilliant he brushed
him away it's it's now the the analogy
of the center of the boxer in the center
of the Ring the aggressive boxes coming
in and this guy's throwing uppercuts and
left Hooks and so he's not letting him
take the center of the ring at the
moment he's winning this
unless you want another Nigel farage I
would also add as well to the point that
he said about British involvement is the
Radcliffe line which was when the
British left uh India Pakistan they
actually drew a set of lines and one set
of lines was the Radcliffe line and the
Red Cliff line is directly involved with
the issue of Kashmir that we see today
and that was drawn by somebody called
Cyril Radcliffe which again was a
British individual so that's why like
Jeremiah Wright who used to be the
um pastor of Obama and he used this
phrase for America but I would say it's
quite evident for the UK as well which
is America's chickens are coming home to
roost and that's exactly what we're
seeing now British involvement in the in
in India for 200 years the drawing of
the the Red Cliff line and also the
Durand Line oh yeah the Durant line
again
a Saxon Pico agreement and all the lines
that they've drawn in Africa in Africa
the Berlin Conference you see yeah so
yeah the truth of is this is what and
also talking about anyway I mean if he's
if he's talking about these things that
happened in Leicester and Birmingham and
there's
is that the violence he's talking about
like what were we talking about here who
was killed who was who was that and in
2011 the head of the conservative in
fact the head of this country was David
Cameron and he said that a lot of things
this was I think in the telegraph or the
guardian we can show it on the screen uh
he admitted that Britain has been a big
cause to the many of the global issues
that we see and he mentioned Kashmir
really so the the prime minister of this
country has admitted that and you're
saying oh why are you bringing it over
here yeah are you not aware it's
ridiculous right yes it's a colonial
narrative but he's doing very well this
man uh I accept that the rapid breakup
in 1947 of empire was done quickly with
a huge loss of life and in retrospect
should have been done differently
absolutely no question about that that
was then this is now but what I said to
you at the beginning are you bringing
the politics of a subcontinent onto the
streets of the West Midlands and we saw
this last year in Leicester you've just
talked about
Modi
the BJP that's correct but here's the
point
Modi is the democratically elected
leader of India he's been elected twice
he'll probably run for a third term also
to answer your question he's also the
Democratic electing leader that is
holding the G20 Summit in occupied
territory International I love this I
love the way he does this that that was
good I think G20 is uh he it shows that
mashallah he's research a topic while
he's aware of the global politics and
G20 thing is a big thing yeah because
that was being held in uh illegally
occupied Kashmir he's reminding people
of the main issue at hand what he's
doing his effective counter punching
he's not allowing farage to say what he
wants to say and use keywords which will
resonate with a western audience
democratically for example democracy of
course being one of the things that
would energize the base he's doing a
very good job in encountering all of the
points that he's making so I I would say
also that Nigel farage seems to be
whitewashing what he's saying by by
using democracy oh you've mentioned all
this but he's a democratically elected
leader but Hitler was also
democratically elected excellent
excellent and that doesn't that doesn't
mean what he did was correct just
because he was democratically elected we
still hold him to account just like we
should be holding him at this point you
just made about Hitler being
democratically elected before it became
the fuhrer and you know done what he'd
done is important because actually the
BJP as you've as you've mentioned in
your public output as have I have
actually got connections the RSS and the
BJP with the Nazi party and they've yes
and they've praised them they have they
have and we're seeing this unusual
collaboration or Coalition between kind
of far-right conservatives and people
who maybe would sympathize with them and
the BJP and we're seeing it kind of play
out here a little bit I think and him
mentioning democracy yes I think is uh
is a loss on his on his behalf rankings
because John Stuart Mill yeah come on in
his book on Liberty he talks and this is
a case again democracy he calls it the
tyranny of majority right of the
majority and that's what we're seeing in
India at the moment with the extremist
majority that are harming the Christians
the Muslims the dalits yeah so we're
we're an excellent point the excellent
point is that you you want to talk about
democracy when it talks about The Ballot
Box but we're not talking about
democracy democracy you can talk about
it in in many different ways it's not
just a democracy is it a pluralistic
liberalistic kind of democracy is this
the state that is referring to itself as
if so let's hold it on those standards
and if we talk about tyranny of the
majority of the idea of minority rights
and so on which liberal democracies in
the West for example Pride themselves on
and theoretically have been mentioned by
the founding fathers of these ideologies
then are the Indians doing what these
people in the ideal world would have
wanted them to do fantastic fantastic
and and to kind of add a little flavor
on that as well what another critique of
democracy is it's leading and how it
leads to populism and demagoguery and
that's exactly what we're seeing here
with Modi he's able to finesse the
crowds with whipping up a hysteria
against and using a minority again
reminiscent of what Hitler did with the
with the Jews and it's a fair comparison
and and we're seeing this and the thing
is if you're bringing democracy can you
also mention and how in in a democracy
you can manipulate public opinion by by
controlling media and we know in India
there's a typical term that's used as
the godi media with the media belongs to
Modi and his party and we saw this even
with you yeah sure yeah even with you
last year we saw with that thing that
happened in Leicester there was a
specific picture of you going around and
the way the Indian media had used that
picture and how they talked about your
involvement and obviously we know each
other the viewers may know you but the
way and they may you know have watched
those clips and those videos as well but
the way the Indian media was able to
mass manipulate that just like that it
shows the effect because here we have a
case study closer to home they do that
regularly but here we saw a case study
of where they're doing it with the UK as
well and recently with the BBC
documentary of Modi as well so that's
it's actually ridiculous ridiculous some
of the stuff that they can say and one
of the lead anchors in India is arnab
goswami who is an absolute vile crypto
creep and Modi is on stage praising him
and saying I watch you really yeah
he is recognized that Kashmir is
occupied territory and this prime
minister is holding his G20 Summit in
occupied territory the fact that the
Saudi government the Chinese government
have backed down should clearly show you
the level of propaganda that this
individual and his organization is going
to we have no issue with people watching
the film our issue is the fact that the
the false propaganda the false narrative
that it perpetuates the film starts with
the fact of it saying it's based on true
events the film had its whole trailer
removed because the unfactual data from
of 32 000 girls we as British kashmiris
we as British Muslims believe that this
film has been pushed out by the Narendra
Modi to discriminate and
disproportionately affect Muslims you
would never have an anti-hindu film you
would never handle angry Jewish films
the 32 000 figure is of course highly
disputed
on the ground and he knows that's a fact
diagnosis would never fly in the Jewish
community no chance at all no no chance
at all you know what he's punching way
above his his height here and you know
it's an opponent he's clearly
underestimated him he's being shamed
live on GBM is this is actually to be
honest I've never seen Nigel farage get
taken down like this
why because I actually Nigel farage was
so good on his issue he was very strong
and he knew the facts you know on his
issue which is the EU and all this kind
of things but when he get when he delves
into other issues yes with people who
know more than him yes he's not
versatile enough to take the Bloods and
the thing is Shaquille hasn't promoted
himself as an academic yeah he's
literally what's the opposite of
Southpaw Orthodox Orthodox so he's seen
him as an orthodox and on this interview
Shaquille has come with the South Pole
and totally totally caught him off guard
because look at the facts that he's
coming out with yeah and and we can also
add in stuff like when when he's talking
about Britain and India and stuff like
that Britain has clearly been involved
in Indian politics because when he was
the Butcher of Gujarat the UK didn't
Bard him from entering the country
that's right the United States didn't
give him a Visa so the UK has been
involved in Indian politics so so I mean
what on Earth is Nigel talking about
it's actually it's in Fury he doesn't
know what he doesn't know what angle to
take you from young women are trafficked
by some extremist Islamic groups and
have been involved in the wars in Syria
and elsewhere cannot be denied it cannot
be done at the same way the right-wing
activists who are shooting up people in
schools the right-wing activists who
have their beliefs you will have
terrorism in every Community you will
have you know violence in every
Community as a British
do you know what I like about it yeah
what I like about what you've done here
bro he said he repeated the same thing
yeah that was a bro it's like he's been
trained yeah I don't know who trained
him but he said the same thing he said
it cannot be denied he didn't deny the
point wow so yeah this is there he took
it he parried the punch and then he just
gave him one pack wow and look I mean
it's like just just like this because
you can't deny this but you can't deny
that yes so it's making the case for the
unremarkable nature Artistry yeah
fantastic now this is what we want to
see bro this is he's really
demonstrating assertiveness and the kind
of rights that you want to see as a
Muslim Community if he can do it bro and
he's not been we haven't seen him in it
we haven't in around debating Forum yeah
then a lot of people can do this bro
this is the kind of model we want to see
is the assertiveness it's the taking the
center of the ring it's not allowing the
interlocutor to to to dictate the the
the trajectory of the conversation he's
doing a fantastic job I want to urge to
every single one of you watching this
you can watch the film but what you must
remember is this is being directly
pushed by the Narendra or the government
just to finish because just to finish
this being pushed the fact that the
government of India is making this tax
free in certain areas said what agenda
do that what agenda do they said
democratically elect whatever we say
about India it is a genuine democracy
the largest act who cares what a
pathetic comeback what a pathetic look
at his face so he looks genuinely
desperate he looks like he's upset
disappointed at his honest person yeah
yes it's a joke Frank democracy in the
world
I could argue that well I think it is
but but I just wanted
really what we're seeing playing out is
the extreme distaste
that many Hindus have the Muslims and
vice versa there is a there's a degree
between the two groups
these are not racist though what's
Muslims are not really it's not a race
it's a real big mistake man that's a
real big mistake that's that's a big
racial hatred that's a big blunder
frankly yeah and you not only is that a
blunder it's it's got nothing to do with
the point of hand well on that bombshell
I'll say that uh I think this is the
kind of representation we want as
Muslims confident assertive
representation where the facts are laid
out he's done an excellent job and this
this film that was you know Bollywood
film that they put out these individuals
it really was it only adds to their
foolishness because no one's taking this
stuff seriously Indian media and film
industry and all this kind of stuff it's
not really credible as a source of
information people are seeing this now
and that's why your man here couldn't
even uh defend you guys properly and
with that I conclude
the prophet Muhammad
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jannah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays that whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale